hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game between eleven-year-old
Judit Polgar and german grandmaster
11:11 Goodman now this game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber one of my
first subscribers Pierre grewcica and he
sent it to me in an email along with a
link the link is to chess chess news
come to an article by McCauley Peterson
basically the BBC UK invited you to
polgár and and - to a podcast where they
talked about girls in chaste women in
chess chess in general a lot of
interesting things about chess I will
put a link to it in the description
below so feel free to check it out it's
very enjoyable and one of the one of the
things that you did blog are mentions in
this podcast is that the first time she
defeated a grandmaster she was 11 years
old and that that grandmaster didn't
really take it that well that after the
game he was banging his head against the
elevator door now in the in the podcast
or in the article your poker doesn't
mention that it's actually live goodman
but she does mention that it's the first
grandmaster she beat and according to
the database eleven is the first
grandmaster she beat so we're still you
know have to figure out if this is in
fact the person but the game is really
great so it doesn't really matter so
let's check it out before checking out
the game i do have a nice photo
challenge for you here it is who is the
gentleman on the right and next to next
to you this polgár so best of luck to
everyone I think you should know who
this person is so once again best of
luck now let's check out this game unit
has the white pieces and she plays efore
the tournament it was played in 1987 in
Brussels in round three so II for c5 and
of course I forgot to reduce the volume
c5 the Sicilian defense Knight to f3 d6
and d4 see capture some d4 Knight
capture some d4 and 90 to f6
we have Knight to c3 so nothing out of
the ordinary here ecigs the feminine
variation Bishop to e2 and the Bishop to
e7 both
sites castle we had f4 and here you
could immediately try and take advantage
of this f4 move by playing Queen to b6
but here white would more than gladly go
for better to e3 and offer this poison
pawn well it's not it's not poison just
yet it depends what bug does with the
position for example Queen captures
Queen d3 and the game goes on and white
gets quite a lot of development for the
price of one point and as you've seen
the quote chosen above the board is your
poker seeing how she was labeled as a
tricky player but she was also known to
be a very aggressive attacking player
you know sort of sort of to the extent
of playing like a like nickel towel so
of course I'll let a good man or even
though she was still only living years
old he knew that she was very strong and
an attacking player so instead he goes a
six here we have Bishop to e3 and now
Queen to c7 you could try and play b5
here it's I mean if you can play b5 you
should always play b5 to prevent wife
from stopping it with a four but
hereafter b5 it's too early white can
punish it with E 5 and after captures
captures the knight is under attack of
95 characters captures here White has
this very nice nice to a5 idea of course
now if you trade Queens Knight captures
on e7 comes with check so you're gonna
lose a piece and only then will will
white recapture the Queen so here you
would have to go Bishop c5 and after
captures you would have to capture the
bishop would to check Knight captures
captures here and after capture so white
would simply be up upon really not
really something you want to do here so
instead you can go b5 immediately first
Queen to c7 guarding against this ePHI
central thrust a for now white doesn't
allow b5 anymore
Knight to c6 and Queen to e1 preparing
to bring the Queen over to g3 Knight to
d7 and Queen to g3 now setting up
everything for the for the King side
attack
Bishop to f6 we have rook a to d1
defending the knight rook to b8 and now
comes Knight captures on c6 b captures
on c6 and now II five
this is a beautiful pawn sacrifice this
if I move simply making room for the
knight on e4 what you decided to go for
for everything here Dee captures on e5
and now Knight to e4 attacking the
bishop on f6 of course if you if you
don't do anything here for example if
you capture here then you have this very
nice idea of capturing the night here
and then if you recapture the night
captures on f6 will be will be deadly as
the g7 pawn is pinned so Bishop to e7
getting the best part of the way we have
f5 now this is no reverse gear unit he
captures on f5 and now comes Bishop to
h6 already on move 18 unit is a
threatening checkmate on g7 we have g6
and now comes if you capture an FA
that's not really doing anything for
white and black will simply recapture
your knight is under attack you have to
move at 92 then comes rook captures on
b2 and with black being up three points
and with the bishop pair
it's the this is all the way blacks game
so after g6 Europe continues in an
aggressive fashion rook captures on f5
we have looked Abby for attacking the
knight on e4 and now simply Bishop to d3
and here the best moves are most often
the the most obvious ones once simply
moving the rook out of the attack would
rope to the 8th which have been very
nice for black but here it seems like
unit has gotten into level Goodman's
head he he it seems he believed her that
moving the rock is is not all that great
so he plays f6 first we have rook D to F
1 even though now after this move
capturing the rook was actually the best
move she doesn't go for material she
still goes for the attack she increases
pressure on DF file rogue d2 f1 doubling
up we have rook captures on e4 bishop
first Bishop captures on f8 King
captures on f8 and now Bishop captures
on f/4g captures on f5 and now Bishop
captures on f5 so after all is said and
done unit now has a look against the
knight and the bishop so this is this is
a better position for black budget
like a buck still has to prove it nice
to be six offering a trade of Bishops
but of course you don't want to trade
we have Bishop captures on h7 now
threatening Queen to g8 checkmate
so of course you do have to block this
Bishop to Bishop to e6 developing the
piece the bishop activating it and also
guarding the g8 square Bishop to e4 and
now comes Knight to d5 Queen to h4 and
here comes Knight to f4 it was extremely
important to start running away with the
King King eating the Seven Kings here
trying tried to hide away the King but
after Knight to f4 it doesn't work
anymore here Queen to h8 was played this
comes with check we have a Bishop to g8
blocking and now rope the d1 black is
still better here but a White has
increased the activity of her pieces you
know the core to quite an extent here
you definitely want to play Queen to b6
check and after King moves Queen to f2
and you still have chances to play this
game of course now Bishop to h7 which is
a White's main idea to win the game will
no longer work as now White has to
constantly keep an eye on this g2
opponent but hereafter look to d1 mister
live Goodman played nice the e6 so here
Queen to the King to h1 immediately by
unit she doesn't want to allow Queen to
b6 shirt so now as we mentioned Queen to
b6 now with the same idea will lose
immediately to Bishop to h7 as now this
doesn't come with check so after King h1
Bishop to d8 now we have Bishop to f5
and here comes Knight to d4 blocking
that look but it doesn't really matter
and attacking the bishop on f5 Bishop to
h3 getting the bishop out of the way and
now white is simply better here so the
best move for black would be Queen to h7
but here black is simply forced to give
back the piece after Queen captures
Bishop captures here comes c3 and your
knight is pinned if you move the knight
you lose the bishop and you can't go
here to protect the bishop because the
bishop is guarding a six and your own c6
pawn is in the way
night coming to see six so this would
have been much better for white as white
is up upon so of course you don't want
to allow this
so Queen to f7 was an idea by Goodman c3
nonetheless by unit polgár and here
comes Queen to b3 attacking the rook on
d1 but now Queen to h6 check King to e7
and now comes rock to f1 immediately
threatening Queen captures on f6
checkmate as you can see the bishop is
controlling the this entire diagonal so
or it wouldn't be checkmate yeah okay
captures and then the King can go here
but I doubt you could actually allow
that so you have to prevent this 96 now
creating an escape route for the King
but it doesn't really help black hole
that much Queen captures on f6 with
check King moves and now comes back up
captures on e6 and it was in fact in
this position on move 37 that 11
resigned the game why did he resign well
of course the the obvious idea Bishop
captures losses to bunch of captures on
b3 Bishop captures and rook captures on
f6 with check white is up two points and
up the exchange of course this is very
much winning
and another thing after Bishop captures
on e6 you could also try Queen captures
on e6 but it doesn't help because now
Queen captures on the 8th the bishop is
now undefended king c5 and now comes
this months to remove rook to F for
controlling the c-4 square now whatever
black plays before will be checkmate and
of course unless you capture the rock
then Queen to d4 will be checkmate
but dia after after this Bishop captures
an e6 move left Goodman resigned the
game and this is the first grandmaster
Judit Polgar ever defeated at the age of
11 so whether this is the same person
who founded and doors of the elevator I
guess we'll never know but definitely an
interesting story so definitely I
thought it was worth sharing so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it feel
free to check out the links in the
description below as usual I would like
to thank Albert Rivera Sawalha
Bern
coningsburgh Advil Garcia and the
dominant orthotics for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with another
interesting video thank you